um the falcons have plenty of control
over their roster they've got a new gm
and terry fontenot new head coach and
arthur smith one of the questions that
was flagged by ownership arthur blank
press conference regarding the firing of
dan quinn and thomas de
blank said hey you know the next coach
and gm are going to decide whether or
not matt ryan and julio jones stay and
as to matt ryan specifically arthur
blank the owner of the team said you
know ryan's going to have a voice in all
of this too well apparently it's all
been worked out fairly quickly according
to nfl media both ryan
and jones will be back now
the actual report is the falcons
plan to keep them
which if you're going to trade them you
can't come out and say we plan to trade
them although it didn't hurt the lions
ultimately it's better to be coy so just
because they're saying they plan to keep
them plans can change at any time we
have no intent to trade percy harvin
your intentions and your planning can
change at any time but at least for now
they're sending out the signals that
they want to go forward with ryan and
jones even though ryan's cap number for
2021 let me check this real quick right
40.9 million dollars
is his cap number for 2021 that cries
out for some sort of an extension some
sort of restructuring that would drive
it down and if you know if he says no
thanks that tells you where his mindset
is so
this one
is one to still keep an eye on
even though the falcons are sending out
the message that they plan to go forward
with the guys they have yeah well and
it's like it's almost a 50 million
dollar dead cap hit too right mike to
where if you cut him if you cut him okay
if you trade him yeah if you trade him i
got to do the math here real quickly um
it's i and i've done the number before
it looks like it's we had 18.6 you had
six more 24. it's still a healthy amount
right to to to move him i think it's
around 37 million to trade him um
but you you still end up with three
million less and you're able to move on
to the new quarterback but i think it
makes the most sense to keep him it
makes the absolute most sense to
restructure his contract right and kick
that can down the road but you know you
just you have to assume he's going to
say yes we we think he will because
typically a player does but if he has
any business reason to want to push back
and maybe get out that's when you think
about saying no yeah i mean it's it's an
interesting situation it really is
because
yeah matt ryan he's at a point of his
career where yeah he's starting to get
up there a little bit you know i don't
think he's a definitive top 10
quarterback in football anymore not like
a definitive i think the last five years
maybe prior to this he was definitive
top seven top eight quarterback in the
league for what he was doing
now i would go
okay he's dancing around ten eleven nine
whatever on certain people's list that
category there the money he's making of
course is huge you know there was a part
of me that thought maybe okay atlanta
falcons julio jones new coaching staff
maybe they rip the band-aid off and go
let's see what we got can get for these
guys out there on the open market and
see if we can't add to our football team
and kind of start over and start from
scratch with a new head coach i thought
maybe there'd be a chance to do that you
know obviously arthur blank thought
maybe that would be a possibility too
but i understand them staying with it i
guess mike i mean you know
taking taking money out of the
conversation
you know do you agree with them sticking
with it i mean i feel like the falcons
almost like we were talking about the
bears
are closer to the top than the bottom
they got a lot of things to like about
their roster there's definitely depth
issues and things like that that they
got to work on but i i guess what i'm
saying is i can understand them staying
with the status quo here how about you
well look either way they got cap issues
so we either have cap issues with our
two-star players or we have cap issues
without our two-star players and it gets
back to the conversation we were having
yesterday about the vikings and kirk
cousins you know the vikings have a big
decision to make about cousins his 35
million dollar
salary for 2022 becomes fully guaranteed
on march 19. but if you move him what
the hell are you going to do at
quarterback for the falcons you know
they because they didn't do a complete
and total freefall last year right it's
not like they're in easy position to go
out and draft their next matt ryan this
is one of the reasons why tanking is
actually a
a good thing for a team that is done to
consider doing because they're caught in
this golf now pete let us know where the
falcons pick they got to be top they're
five or six though right right in there
but they they won it they won too many
games they're not gonna have one of the
prime picks they won too many games down
the stretch i'd say they're in the top
ten oh they're four well still the best
quarterbacks are going to be gone you're
going to have to move up if you want to
try to get one of the top quarterbacks
most likely it puts him in a tough spot
and again plan to keep to me
is different from actually definitely
will be on the game day right plan to
keep means we're planning on keeping him
but if you call with a great offer we'll
change our plans and then we'll think
about drafting a quarterback at number
four or doing that you know there should
be somebody there
i don't think it's going to be like
lawrence you know justin fields the kid
zach wilson uh zach wilson right from
byu i'm sorry i don't have all these
college guys names ingrained in my brain
yet i don't think it's gonna be one two
three just right right off the bat of
the draft so i would think sitting there
at four
that they can certainly get a
quarterback now whether they like one of
those other guys other than trevor
lawrence who i think is really right now
the only
slam dunk guy you could just go every
team likes them everybody knows he's a
stud everybody else is i think still
doing their homework on the other guys
but
it is a possibility and that's where i
thought maybe they could go this off
season and kind of just start a new era
there in atlanta but it doesn't sound
like that's going to happen
yeah i've been doing more math on this
dead cap number it may actually be more
than 40 million i'm 49. it's not 49
right but it may be more than 40 when
you put all this together and this is
what happens when
you restructure see you restructure to
reduce a guy's cap number those cap
dollars don't just disappear into thin
air those cap dollars get moved into
future years so there's always a
reckoning and the problem this year
because the cap is likely going to go
down
that reckoning is going to be more
painful which makes it imperative to
push as much of the reckoning as
possible into future years you have to
have ryan on board with that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports